die ebola epidemie ist zum
internationalen gesundheitsnotstand
erklärt worden
ein erster ebola fall ist in saudi
arabien aufgetreten und die usa
entwickeln derzeit ein wirksames
medikament gegen die solche das und mehr
sind die themen jetzt in den kriegs und
top five news auch dieses mal
ausschließlich mit news zur epidemie
die whu die weltgesundheitsorganisation
hat den internationalen
gesundheitsnotstand ausgerufen zuvor
hatte nigeria nach zwei weiteren
infektionen den nationalen notstand
bekannt gegeben
damit kann die whu jetzt noch aktiver
eingreifen
das bedeutet quarantänemaßnahmen aber
auch grenzschließung und einschränkungen
im internationalen reiseverkehr können
jetzt durch die whu erlassen werden
die nationalen regierungen von liberia
und sierra leone haben bereits städte
abgeriegelt in liberia sperrt derzeit
die armee sämtliche zufahrten in die
hauptstadt monrovia mit allen mitteln
wird versucht die ebola solche in den
griff zu bekommen
spanien holt infizierten 1
der 75 jährige spanier miguel park
jahres hat sich in liberia mit dem ebola
virus infiziert und wurde jetzt von der
spanischen regierung nach hause holt den
antrag unterstützen zehntausende spanier
in einer online petition beim transport
wurden die strengsten sicherheits und
quarantänebestimmungen der whu
eingehalten
damit ist spanien das zweite westliche
land nach den usa das seine staatsbürger
im eigenen land behandeln lässt
erster fall in saudi arabien ein araber
kehrte von seiner reise in sierra leone
zurück und verstarb kürzlich die
todesursache ist noch nicht genau
bekannt ist wird allerdings sehr stark
vermutet dass sein tod mit der ebola
epidemie in verbindung steht also dass
er eh boller hatte vor seinem tod wurde
er in ein krankenhaus in der hafenstadt
dschidda mit dem verdacht auf eine
infektion eingeliefert für pilger aus
sierra leone guinea und liberia erteilte
die regierung saudi-arabiens
mittlerweile aus sicherheitsgründen ein
einreiseverbot also es werden keine
wiesn mehr ausgegeben
diese regelung soll auch auf weitere
länder ausgeweitet werden indem sich der
ebola virus verbreitet
die weltbank unterstützt westafrika im
kampf gegen die epidemie bis zu 200
millionen us dollar das sind etwa 149
millionen euro sollen den betroffenen
ländern zu kommen zudem hat die
afrikanische entwicklungsbank eine
unterstützung von 60 millionen zugesagt
die weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
bereits hilfsgelder im wert von 100
millionen zugesichert
die bilanz der ebola epidemie
verschlimmert sich dabei weiter die zahl
der toten nähert sich nämlich jetzt
immer schneller den 1000 leider hat sich
das virus jetzt auch in nigeria
verbreitet nachdem ein infizierter mann
in lagos zusammengebrochen war sind nun
fünf weitere fälle bestätigt worden
unter anderem zeigen ein arzt und zwei
männer die symptome einer infektion an
ebola nigeria und vor allem die stadt
lagos sind jetzt besonders besorgt
werden in der stadt mit zehn millionen
einwohnern könnte sich das virus
ziemlich schnell verbreiten die sowieso
schon unkontrollierte situation würde
sich so drastisch verschärfen die usa
haben ein medikament gegen ebola in 55
bis 90 der fälle überleben die
infizierten dass wir uns ja nicht die
medizin ist bislang nahezu machtlos nur
bei einer frühzeitigen erkennung kann
den betroffenen wirklich geholfen werden
deshalb wurde in atlanta usa unter
strengsten quarantäne bedingungen zwei
amerikanische medizinern ein serum
verabreicht die sich in afrika
angesteckt hatten bislang wurde es zwar
nur an affen getestet aber aufgrund der
notsituation wurden die infizierten
ärzte jetzt damit behandelt in beiden
fällen zeigte das medikament eine
positive wirkung die heilung schreitet
voran
es ist damit der erste lichtblick im
kampf gegen die tödliche seuche bis das
medikament allerdings massentauglich ist
wird es noch etwas dauern meinen die
entwickler wie genau nämlich das serum
wirkt wissen die behandeln mediziner
selbst nicht in den usa gab es teils
harte kritik am ob transport der ärzte
besonders in atlanta war die angst vor
einer ausbreitung des erregers auf
amerikanischem boden groß die
bevölkerung konnte allerdings beruhigt
werden denn die emery klinik in atlanta
ist eine der modernsten isolierstationen
der usa die eu stuft die gefahr von
ebola für europa noch niedrig ein
dennoch gelten reisewarnung
was bisher geschah findet ihr alles hier
in der playlist zum thema ebola hier
klicken in der app gibt es täglich news
dafür hier klicken
und alle links sind wie immer auch in
der video beschreibung habt ihr die
aktuelle entwicklung beobachtet was ist
euer eindruck sind die politiker in
panik oder läuft alles einigermaßen
geplant ab diskutiert es mit mir in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran